En fait, c'est plus grand que les scouts aux États-Unis.
Et nous ne sommes pas homophobes.
(Rires)
Il est vrai que nous communiquons avec les jeunes par SMS,
car c'est ainsi que les jeunes communiquent.
Nous lancerons plus de 200 campagnes cette année.
Des choses telles que la collecte de beurre de cacahouètes
pour les banques alimentaires
ou confectionner des cartes de Saint Valentin
pour les citoyens âgés à mobilité réduite.
Nous leur enverrons un SMS
et nous aurons un taux de réponse de 97%.
Et plus encore dans les communautés hispaniques et les banlieues.
Nous avons collectés 200 000 pots de beurre de cacahouètes
et plus de 365 000 cartes de Saint Valentin.
C'est énorme.
(Applaudissements)
Mais il y a un effet secondaire étrange.
Chaque fois que nous envoyons un SMS,
nous recevons des dizaines de messages
n'ayant rien à voir avec le beurre de cacahouètes,
la famine ou les citoyens âgés --
mais des SMS sur le fait d'être maltraité,
d'être accro à la marijuana.
Le pire message que nous ayons reçu était mot pour mot celui-ci :
« Il n'arrête pas de me violer.
C'est mon père.
Il m'a dit de n'en parler à personne. Vous êtes là ? »
Nous ne pouvions pas y croire.
Nous ne pouvions pas croire qu'une chose aussi horrible
puisse arriver à un être humain
et qu'elle le partage avec nous alors que c'était si intime et personnel.
Nous avons réalisé qu'il fallait arrêter de les trier
et mettre en place une ligne SMS de crise pour ces personnes qui souffraient.
Nous avons lancé Crisis Text Line,
très discrètement, à Chicago et El Paso -- quelques milliers de personnes par marché.
En seulement 4 mois, nous étions partout aux États-Unis.
Pour y donner un contexte,
c'est aucune publicité et une croissance plus rapide que Facebook à ses débuts.
(Applaudissements)
Les SMS sont incroyablement personnels.
Personne ne vous entend parler.
Nous nous manifestons tous les jours à midi.
Les enfants sont à table
et vous pensez qu'elle envoie un SMS au garçon mignon au bout du couloir
mais elle nous envoie un SMS sur sa boulimie.
Nous ne recevons de « genre » ou « hum » ou d'hyperventilation ou des pleurs.
Nous ne recevons que des faits.
Nous recevons des choses comme : « Je veux mourir.
J'ai une tablette de cachets sur le bureau devant moi. »
Et le conseiller de crise dit :
« Pourquoi ne mets-tu pas ces cachets dans le tiroir pendant qu'on parle ? »
Et ils s'envoient quelques messages.
Le conseiller de crise obtient l'adresse de la fille,
car si vous contactez une ligne de crise, vous voulez de l'aide.
Le conseiller obtient l'adresse
et déclenche un sauvetage actif
pendant qu'ils discutent par SMS.
Puis, le silence :
23 minutes sans réponse de la part de cette fille.
Et le message suivant arrive,
il provient de la mère :
« Je ne savais pas, alors que j'étais aussi dans la maison.
Nous sommes dans l'ambulance en route pour l'hôpital. »
En tant que mère ce message...
Le message suivant arrive un mois plus tard.
« Je viens de sortir de l'hôpital.
J'ai été diagnostiquée bipolaire, je crois que ça ira. »
(Applaudissements)
J'aimerais vous dire que c'est un échange inhabituel
mais nous faisons en moyenne 2,41 sauvetages actifs par jour.
30% de nos SMS traitent de suicide et de dépression, c'est énorme.
Ce qui est beau à propos de la Crisis Text Line,
c'est que ce sont des inconnus qui conseillent d'autres inconnus
sur les problèmes les plus intimes
et qui leur permettent d'aller mieux.
C'est excitant. Je vous dirais
que nous avons reçu au total plus de 6,5 millions de SMS
en moins de deux ans.
(Applaudissements)
Ce qui m'excite vraiment à ce propos,
ce qui m'enthousiasme ce sont les données :
6,5 millions de messages,
c'est le volume, la vélocité et la variété pour produire un corpus juteux.
Nous pouvons faire un travail préventif.
Nous pouvons faire tous types de conclusions et d'apprentissages
grâce à ce jeu de données.
Nous pouvons faire mieux et améliorer le monde.
Comment utiliser les données pour nous rendre meilleurs ?
Statistiquement, quelqu'un ici, quelqu'un regardant ceci
a vu un thérapeute ou un psy à un moment dans sa vie,
pas besoin de lever la main.
(Rires)
Comment savez-vous que cette personne est bien ?
Il a un diplôme d'Harvard accroché au mur ?
Êtes-vous sûr qu'il n'a pas fini dernier de la promo ?
(Rires)
Quand mon mari et moi avons vu une conseillère maritale,
je la trouvais géniale car elle a dit :
« Je vous revois dans 2 semaines mais je revois monsieur dans 1 semaine. »
(Rires)
Nous savons ce qui fait un excellent conseiller.
Nous savons que si vous utilisez les mots « engourdi » et « manche »,
il y a 99% de chances qu'il y ait mutilation.
Si vous envoyez les mots « mg » et « ruban de caoutchouc »,
il y a 99% de chances qu'il y ait consommation de drogue.
Et nous savons que si vous envoyez « sexe », « oral » et « Mormon »,
vous questionnez votre sexualité.
C'est une information intéressante que pourrait utiliser un conseiller
mais l'algorithme dans nos mains signifie un message automatique disant :
« 99% de risques de mutilation, essayez de poser une de ces questions »
qui est envoyé au conseiller.
ou « 99% de risques de consommation de drogue,
voici 3 centres de désintoxication proches de l'envoyeur. »
Cela nous rend plus précis.
Le jour du suicide de Robin Williams,
les gens ont inondé les lignes de crise du pays.
Il est triste de voir une icône, un homme drôle, se suicider.
Il y avait 3 heures d'attente sur toutes les lignes de crise du pays.
Nous avons également eu un pic de volume.
La différence est que
si vous nous envoyez « Je veux mourir » ou « Je veux me tuer »,
les algorithmes le lisent, vous avez le code orange
et vous êtes premiers sur la liste.
Nous pouvons traiter par sévérité et non par ordre d'arrivée.
(Applaudissements)
Les données rendent le monde meilleur
parce que je suis assise sur la première carte mondiale
de crises en temps réel.
Pensez-y :
ces 6,5 millions de messages,
la détection automatique, via des processus de langage naturel,
toutes ces données.
Le pire jour de la semaine pour les désordres alimentaires est le lundi.
La pire heure de la journée pour la consommation de drogue est 5h du matin.
Et le Montana est un très bel endroit à visiter
mais vous ne voulez pas y vivre
car c'est le premier État en termes d'idées suicidaires.
J'ai rendu ces données publiques, libres et ouvertes.
Nous avons retiré toutes les informations personnelles.
Cela s'appelle CrisisTrends.org
Je veux que les écoles puissent voir
que le lundi est le pire jour pour les désordres alimentaires
afin qu'elles puissent prévoir des menus
et que les conseillers soient présents le lundi.
Et je veux que les familles voient que la consommation de drogue
est plus forte à 5h du matin.
Je veux que quelqu'un du Montana s'occupe des réserves indiennes.
(Applaudissements)
Les données, les preuves
améliorent les lois, la recherche,
le journalisme, la police, les conseils d'administration scolaires.
Je ne me vois pas comme étant une activiste de la santé mentale.
Je me vois comme une activiste nationale de la santé.
Les données m'excitent, je suis un peu geek.
Cela était trop efféminé.
Je suis une geek.
(Rires)
J'aime les données.
La seule différence entre moi et ces gens en sweat dans la rue,
avec ces entreprises basées sur le gras, est que cela ne m'intéresse pas
de vous aider à trouver à Dallas de la nourriture chinoise à 2 heures du matin
ou que vous touchiez votre poignet et obteniez immédiatement une voiture
ou couchiez avec quelqu'un.
Je suis inspirée --
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Je veux utiliser cette technologie, ces données pour rendre le monde meilleur.
Je veux aider cette fille
qui a envoyé un SMS disant que son père la violait.
Car nous n'avons plus eu de nouvelles d'elle.
J'espère qu'elle est quelque part en sécurité et en bonne santé
et qu'elle voit cette conférence
et sait que son désespoir
et son courage ont inspiré la création la Crisis Text Line
et m'inspire chaque jour.
(Applaudissements)